for ABC ESPN Doc Rivers is out our dear
friend has decided that life as an NBA
broadcaster is way too stressful so he's
decided to opt for a less stressful job
an NBA head coach on a team that's
trying to win a championship we thank
him for all his many weeks of service
and we wish him all luck in the world
seriously Doris we're a little
heartbroken today disappointed but we're
thrilled for our friend because coaching
is in his blood it's what he loves to do
and this is a tremendous opportunity in
a city that he has history in he does
selfishly I'm going to miss him I'm
going to try not to choke up here doc
just brought unbelievable energy every
single day he was positive he threw
himself into what we were trying to do
but the question is no longer what he
can do for you and I Mike it's what can
he do for a 30 win Buck team and even
through all that success something felt
a Miss in Milwaukee but our friend has
got a legit shot to compete in the East
and I'm going to try to be happy for you
doc